They soared like a plastic meteor straight
into the sun and had a company-wide meltdown.
Here's why Funko dumped $30 million of toys
in a landfill, and where they're going next.
Funko's humble beginnings date back to 1998, when
toy enthusiast Mike Becker started the business
from his home. For seven years, the company
experienced modest success in selling bobbleheads,
including characters such as the Big Boy mascot,
the Cheerios honey bee, Popeye, and others.
In 2005, fellow toy enthusiast Brian
Mariotti recognized Funko's potential
and bought the company from Becker. Shortly
after, Mariotti pivoted slightly away from
bobbleheads with a new line of nostalgic-themed
figurines called Fantastik Plastik. Soon,
Funko began expanding its licensing into
movies, television, and video games,
and showcasing their products
nationwide at different conventions.
"I think we knew right then and there
that we had something on our hands."
By 2011, Funko would hit its stride with
a new line of products that would put the
company on a fast track to becoming
a global phenomenon. Cue Funko Pop.
Funko's Pop Vinyl line popped up on the
scene as early as 2010, when Brian Mariotti
debuted the prototype at the 2010 San Diego
Comic-Con. Originally named Funko Force 2.0,
the line featured characters from the
DC Universe, including Green Lantern,
Bat Girl, and two versions of Batman. One year
later, with some slight design adjustments,
they were introduced at the New
York Toy Fair as Funko Pops.
Funko Pops stood out with their large square
heads, disproportionately small bodies, round,
pupilless eyes, and traditionally
no mouth, although certain variants
included this feature. Despite their toy-like
appearance, Funko Pop's driving consumers were
adults rather than children because, unlike
traditional action figures or bobbleheads,
Funko Pop was the first of its kind to offer
something new, leaving no franchise untapped.
"It's like a friend that'll never leave
you because you turned into a zombie."
The Pop line has since expanded to include
other merchandise, such as apparel, plushies,
and keychains. As time progressed, the Funko
company as a whole only continued to evolve.
A pop culture company like Funko is built on
licensing agreements, which permit Funko to
use the licensor's intellectual property. Since
the company's inception, its licenses have grown
to include more than 1,000 different properties
from some of the biggest names in pop culture and
entertainment. These properties range from movies,
TV, and video games to anime, sports, and music,
allowing Funko to produce thousands of characters
— if not tens of thousands — in multiple variants.
Although franchises such as "Star
Wars" and "Harry Potter" are some
of their best-selling products, Brian
Mariotti assured License Global that
Funko wasn't interested in only producing
figures that made the most money. He said:
"We're going to drive development
based on the characters that mean
the most to us. We want to represent the
brands as best we can, and that doesn't
mean cherry-picking the main characters
and not doing the tertiary characters."
"Is it stupid to have a code, to have honor?"
"Big words for a little man."
"Yeah."
In an era of sequels and remakes
and the luxury of built-in fandoms,
it seemed only natural that Funko
could stand the test of time.
Funko stock went public on November 2, 2017,
setting its IPO at $12 per share, with hopes
to raise upwards of $125 million. Their first day
return made headlines, but not for the reasons one
would want. Despite pricing lower than expected,
Funko shares dropped 41.1 percent, closing at
a meager $7.07. Their stock launch was dubbed the
"worst first-day return for an IPO in 17 years."
But this bump in the road wasn't enough to deter
the company. Brian Mariotti explained to GeekWire:
"I told our employees, no matter what
happens, whether the stock goes up,
or the stock goes down, it's kind of
irrelevant because we haven't changed
anything that we said we are going to do in
the future or what we are currently doing now."
Less than a year later,
Funko stock resurged by exceeding its
original $12 pricing. Now that's a pop.
"Pop pop."
Business was on the rise. In addition
to selling straight to the consumer,
Funko expanded to big box retailers as well
as smaller local shops nationwide. In 2019,
Funko opened its biggest storefront in Los
Angeles. In their press release, Funko promised,
"The 40,000-square-foot Hollywood location will
be brimming with highly shareable social
media moments, including life-size Funko
statues and immersive 'sets' inspired by
some of the biggest pop culture fandoms."
Funko reached $1 billion in sales in 2021, a 58
percent increase from the year before. But the
company wasn't the only thing increasing
in value. Individual Pop figures started
reselling at an all-time high. Retail
prices typically ranged from $10-$15,
but if you were lucky enough to get your hands
on certain exclusive or limited edition stock,
they could be worth upwards of $25,000. In fact,
Funko Pop's value skyrocketed so much that some
even resorted to thievery. Most notably,
a New York City man accidentally knocked
an elderly woman unconscious while fleeing a
Barnes and Noble with $35 worth of Funko Pops.
"You know, they're obsessed. It's
a great business you got here."
At this point, many considered their
collections as investments. According
to NASDAQ, the top three most valuable Funko
Pops in 2022 included Alex from "A Clockwork
Orange," Freddy Funko as Venom, and
Metallic Stan Lee. And in May 2022,
the largest resale in Funko history
took place in Glendale, California,
where a man purchased a rare golden Willy Wonka
set accompanied by a golden ticket for $100,000.
As far as Funko Pop consumers go, there are
two types who make up the majority of Funko's
sales. There are the dedicated collectors
who never miss a release and display their
vast array of prized possessions for all to
see, and the other is the casual buyer who
only picks up specific Funko Pop characters
from their favorite franchises. No matter
which category a consumer falls under, you're no
more or no less a part of the Funko community.
The online community expands further outside
the company, with collectors posting their own
content online centered around Funko. YouTube
creators engage with fellow fans by showcasing
their collections, product unboxings, and keeping
subscribers up to date on Funko news. Funko Pop
groups sell, trade, and share on Facebook.
But nothing compares to the magic felt when
hundreds of Funko fanatics gather in person
at conventions and events. Debuting exclusive
lines and interacting with the community
has enabled Funko to carve out a significant
space at conventions such as Comic-Con,
Fan Expo, Star Wars Celebration, and E3.
"Hulkmania is running wild."
"Brother!"
"I can't."
Although Funko has gained a loyal following,
fans aren't afraid to speak up against
unfavorable choices made by the company.
Take, for example, Funko's venture into
NFTs. In 2021, Funko announced its entry
into the NFT market and was met with a
poor response. As one Reddit user wrote:
"They've shown they don't really
understand the NFT market,
and have just seen it as an opportunity to
increase the bottom line, dramatically."
More criticism followed after
Funko released a Bob Ross NFT,
going against the artist's wishes of wanting
to avoid using his likeness for profit.
NFT scandals didn't mark the end
of Funko's controversies. Fans were
surprised when Funko released a dead
Laura Palmer figure from "Twin Peaks."
A Change.org petition was even created to ban the
character. More recently, Funko came under fire
for supposedly whitewashing the character Prince
Naveen from "The Princess and the Frog." The
company Twitter account deleted the original image
and released a follow-up statement which said:
"Our previous post showed an
image of the Naveen Funko Pop!
that is not true to the product,
which is accurately shown here."
Still, this wouldn't be the
company's first offense in this area,
with similar accusations leveled at
it in the past. These controversies
combined have been enough to cause
some distrust in the company.
What was once considered a key selling point
for Funko became its greatest flaw. As far
as Funko is concerned, the company is in the
business of creating something for everyone.
Not only are there thousands of characters to
choose from, but there's also a long list of
variants for each character. Chase variants
offer an alternative version of a character,
including anything from an outfit change
to a glow-in-the-dark appearance. Flocked
variants replace the vinyl texture with
a soft, fuzzy one. Diamond variants add
a shimmer of glitter to characters. The
list continues with chrome, metallic,
and black light variants. Comedian and television
host Conan O'Brien had 34 variants alone.
"Yeah, otherwise known as Conan
without coffee and makeup."
Perhaps it became too much. When Funko's
third quarter report for 2022 was released,
the company revealed that there
was an issue involving a surplus
in inventory. To make matters worse, chains
were delaying or canceling orders. Overall,
the third quarter of 2022 reported a 39 percent
decline in net income from the previous year. In
an attempt to push out more supply, more
and more Funko products began popping up
in discount stores and hitting clearance
shelves. Still, the worst was yet to come.
Funko's fourth quarter report for
2022 proved just how detrimental the
damage had become. Brian Mariotti
revealed in a conference call:
"A combination of macro factors
and Funko-specific issues have
disrupted our financial and operating
performance to an unacceptable degree."
One of these factors was the exponential
cost of housing excess inventory. Part
of the company's solution made shocking headlines:
since attempting to sell off the inventory
at a discounted price wasn't cutting it,
Funko instead made the decision to dump at least
$30 million worth of product into a landfill.
"So where are we now?"
"In the garbage truck on the way to the dump."
Between the waste, environmental concerns, and
inconsideration with regards to this decision,
fans of Funko were disappointed, to
say the least. One Reddit user said:
"This is most likely just another
example of corporate greed. They
would rather throw unsold merchandise
away than donate it or give it away."
But is bad press enough to
tank the company for good?
While all this was going on, Funko's stock
continued to drop after a drastic fall
following 2022's third quarter earnings. NASDAQ
reported that the stock dropped a whopping 59.3
percent. Funko's downfall became a numbers
game, with the company on the losing end.
"It's extra surprising, too,
given that Funko reported better than
expected revenue in the latest quarter."
Comparing 2021 and 2022's fourth quarter
reports, net sales decreased by one percent,
while net income decreased by a
staggering 368 percent. However,
the company kept up an optimistic
front, writing in the report,
"Funko is highly focused on identifying and
addressing opportunities for improvement. However,
these initiatives will take several
quarters in some cases, and as a result,
we expect sequential improvement throughout
the year as our initiatives take hold."
What exactly does all this mean for the future of
Funko? Many factors come into play when analyzing
what went wrong between 2021's record-breaking
profits and the shortcomings of the second
half of 2022. When comparing Funko to other
collectibles that eventually faded into obscurity,
such as Beanie Babies, the pattern becomes
more clear. Commonality and similarity are
slowly hurting Funko's collectible brand. As Funko
tries to cater to everyone by creating Funko Pops
for everything under the pop culture sun, the only
value comes from consumers buying at retail price.
During the height of the COVID pandemic, people
clung to entertainment and hobbies for comfort.
Funko products weren't exactly new, but their
virality drew in an excited new crowd. However,
as time went on, that excitement diminished
slightly. Of course, this doesn't mean no one
is buying Funko products. There was still a 29
percent increase in net sales for the full fiscal
year of 2022, compared to 2021. So if Funko can
sort out its supply issues and bring a new level
of excitement back to the collector community,
there could still be hope for the future.